For this quiz, your goal is to define the procedure add page to index
that takes 3 inputs. The 1st is the index,
and I've drawn a picture of index to remind you of its structure--
and it's a list where each entry in the list is a list containing a key,
and the list of the URLs where that keyword is found.
The 2nd input is the URL--
so that's the location of the page, where the content came from--
And the 3rd input is the content.
That's the entire text of the page at that location where URL is.
The results should be updating the index to include all word occurrences
found in the page content by adding the URL to the words associated URL list.
I'll show you a few examples so it is clear what add to index should do,
and then you'll have a chance to define it yourself.
We're going to start with an empty index--
and we'll call add page to index--
and let's print out what index looks like after this--
it's a little hard to see like that, so let's see what index position zero is.
We can see that the keyword this appears at the URL "fake test"
if we print index at position 1
we'll see the same thing, but this time for the keyword is.
We have an entry,
we have an index,
we have 4 words in our index
this is a and test
and for each word, the list of URLs where each word appears is fake.test
which is what we passed in as the URL here.
Let's try adding some other things to our index.
This time, we'll add a page called real.test.
and have the content of the page be this is not a test.
Now, when we run this, we see this index
if we look at a particular element--let's look at the element at position 2--
it has 2 entries in its URL list--
since both of the pages we passed in contain is--
and if you look at index position 4--
we see that for the word not--that only appears on the real.test page--
so there's only 1 entry in it's URL list.
We already defined the procedure for respond to new query.
So, that should work on this index. Let's try.
Look up takes the index and the keyword and returns the list of URLs at that keyword.
Delete the previous tests, and see what happens when we look up is,
we see that it occurs on both pages--
if we look up udacity--it doesn't occur anywhere so far.
I hope it's clear now what add to index page should do--
see if you can write the code to define add page to index.